get ready for Professor Hillary yes
that's right the former secretary of
state will be co-teaching a foreign
policy course at Columbia later this
year it will be called Inside The
Situation Room very original name and
she just released a video to promote it
yummy you're running again
well I sure am Karen I just got here
early for the new class we're teaching
together on foreign policy decision
making classes don't start until
September yeah but I wanted to be
prepared Karen you know when it comes to
crisis situations you've always got to
be prepared prepared I think you're more
prepared than anyone to teach this
course and I'll cover what it was
actually like in the room during the bin
Laden raid the Iran sanctions the Gaza
ceasefire you name it okay but are you
ready for whatever questions the
students throw at you bring it on do you
think they will ask her what difference
does this make judge uh you know what I
imagine no one will ask her that because
they will be so enamored by Hillary
Clinton the presidential candidate the
Secretary of State they won't even
consider the fact that she flip-flopped
on most foreign policy issues uh and
that she isn't someone that whether it's
the Iraq War the Middle East Russia
China trans-pacific partnership This
Woman's been on every side of every
issue so in that regard she is quite
experienced Jesse they must have a lot
of money because that was kind of a
highly produced video you couldn't tell
they brought in the big lighting yeah
and makeup and everything a lot of
production bad acting that was very
stilted even for Hillary that delivery
was bad and why are they calling it
inside the Situation Room the last time
I saw her inside the Situation Room all
the guys were looking at the screen
during the raid and she was going
that was a little embarrassing why do
they need to do this or do they just
have a lot of money so they can yeah
it's not things like this
it's a big gap for the school I mean
every University yeah every University
oh okay I was like did I have to fight
you on this channel
um you know everyone would want Hillary
to come and teach a course and to be
part of it she is and I understand
obviously I'm the only person at the
table who feels this way she's
completely iconic and she does have a
lot of important experience to share and
even if you didn't like the way that she
was holding her hands when they took out
Bin Laden she's still there when they
took out Bin Laden it's a pretty big
deal so if I was a cepa student I would
be thrilled by the fact that I could
listen to him I think about this all the
time and I've heard him speak a number
of times and found it Fascinating People
line up to listen to Henry Kissinger
it's got some pretty big oopsies on his
resume and so yeah she's on two sides of
the trans-pacific partnership who cares
okay
so do you think if she invited a guest
speaker who might
um trigger somebody in the audience that
she would defend the Free Speech rights
of somebody that the kids might disagree
with that's a tough question can I pass
on that one you can do whatever you want
all right uh she could have saved that
skit with one line just say she should
have just looked right at the camera at
the end of that and said Epstein didn't
kill himself
and then
yeah what is she gonna teach him like
what is she really gonna what are you
gonna learn from that by the way it's
the other lady who's going to do all the
heavy lifting right teacher's assistant
yeah yeah she's getting by and by the
second class they're gonna hate each
other right that's why you're gonna like
the classes to watch the passive
aggressive glares and and and and
interruptions between the two it's going
to be fantastic it is going to be
fantastic she's good and then Hillary's
gonna make it look like a suicide oh no
and a mysterious accident in the woods
jelly beans everywhere jelly beans
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else